a very interesting discussions this
morning on the david pakman show
subreddit where you can join 26 maybe
it's 27 now
26 27 000 other david pakman show
viewers
davidpakman.com reddit
a few interesting posts you know i got a
few emails like this
and this is a post from portland hipster
who said
david why on earth would you not tell
republicans not to vote in georgia if
you can convince an already
psychologically damaged
or duped republican to not vote for more
destruction
isn't that the morally correct thing to
do in all likelihood having a
democratic-controlled senate would
benefit these deranged republicans in
material ways so don't you have a moral
obligation to help get a
democratic-controlled senate by any
ethical way possible
doesn't that trump your principle of
voting no i don't think so
what i said earlier this week and last
week is one of the main
one of the big messages the top-level
messages
on this show is engaging people in the
political processes
and part of that is increasing voter
turnout and everyone must vote everyone
must vote everyone must vote
and so because that's the big principle
what this user is doing
is engaging in a special pleading which
is well yes
get more people involved vote vote vote
accept
this time whereby buying into
obviously false conspiracy theories that
the election is rigged
and abandoning the principle of
increasing engagement
you might serve a greater good right the
argument is well you know
your argument david about more
engagement is generally good
but here democrats taking the senate
would create so much good it would
trickle down
it's justified morally this time
for you to lie to people and say you
know what republicans you're right it's
rigged and you should stay home
this is exactly one of the points i've
been making just because i might be able
to justify it
in this micro case i'm not going to
abandon the macro principle and i don't
think the left needs to
i don't think the left you know when i
say guys listen
um i want to change campaign finance but
right now
the candidate that raises the most money
wins and the candidate that buys tv ads
uh is more likely to win we've got to do
it we we can't unilaterally
disarm uh because then we'll just never
win
this is different this is a principle of
engagement and civic duty and voting and
so
i wouldn't feel okay abandoning it here
and saying yeah you guys the
it is rigged you should you should stay
home republicans don't vote i just
wouldn't feel good about it others might
it's a
decision you'll have to make for
yourselves um user brody mulligan
says if offered to you and available
immediately would you take pfizer's
covid 19 vaccine
you know at this point i would now based
on what i've been seeing
um based on my risk profile and
demographic information
i am not likely to be able to get a
vaccine until april may or june
as of right now if half the country ends
up not wanting it that that might
accelerate and it might be moved up
at this point i have seen enough of the
data and pfizer
bioentec released detailed data um two
days ago about the vaccine
uh that i would take it i know that
there's roughly a a 10
chance that i would have some kind of a
reaction
physical reaction in the arm i'm not
someone who's had prior
uh allergic reactions to vaccines
and so that is not a concern to me and
the data to me
would be if if i wasn't taking it from
anybody who needs it more acutely than i
do today
i would take the pfizer bioentec vaccine
curious to hear from folks in the
audience where you stand about that
you can join the discussion and even
vote in the poll
asking about the pfizer vaccine um
by joining the subreddit it's free i'm
not selling you anything just join the
community
at davidpakman.com reddit